the palace staying mum on claims meghan
markle bullied royal staffers the queen
doesn't want any more drama
little nazix calls for change following
an awards show snub and beyonce's mom
teases her new music i'm as excited as
everybody else i can't wait for you guys
to hear it she put two years of love
into this et's the download starts right
now
[Music]
we start with round two of the battle
between blac chyna and rob kardashian
the exes won't be headed to trial in her
so-called revenge porn case the et has
confirmed they've reached a settlement
the terms are still unclear chyna
accused rob of posting explicit photos
of her on social media without her
consent when the two accused each other
of cheating in 2017. the settlement
comes almost two months after china lost
a hundred million dollar defamation case
against rob and his family and the rest
of the kardashian family is putting
their differences aside to celebrate
father's day while boyfriend pete
davidson is off working in australia kim
called her ex kanye the best dad in this
photo of the rapper and their four kids
thanking him for loving them the way you
do the tribute comes two weeks after
pete was spotted spending time with
saint a source tells e.t that pete is
great with kim's kids which has made her
fall even harder and though kanye is
jealous he's decided to take a step back
he's getting to a point where he has no
other choice but to try and be
understanding kimye reconnected in
person over the weekend too for daughter
north's basketball game and niece true's
dance recital also at the recital chloe
and her ex tristan thompson the two were
also spotted at a family lunch just days
after his affair publicly played out on
the season finale of the kardashians
everything is an act of betrayal
everything is a lie everything is
manipulation it's deceit to tristan have
every opportunity to tell me yes was
tristan going to tell me if there wasn't
a baby involved absolutely not and that
shows a lot about his character the
entire thing is despicable now the
outing comes as chloe shuts down new
relationship rumors so a popular
kardashian fan account reposted an
anonymous dumas submission claiming the
reality star is dating another nba
player now chloe quickly set the record
straight commenting definitely not true
i am not seeing a soul i am happy
focusing on my daughter and myself for a
while a source told e.t in april she's
going with the flow and not pushing
herself to find love again
you don't feel nothing
nothing is healing
time is just killing
okay so tristan on the other hand is
raising some eyebrows in a surprise
cameo yeah he played the part of drake's
best man in the rapper's new music video
for falling back and of all things
tristan offers up marriage advice you
ready
yeah i'm ready it doesn't feel right we
scrap it we go home it's done
no no i'm good bro i'm ready to
to settle down i'm in love so high for
you
don't do this guy get you right here
yeah yeah please get me right yeah yeah
i'm gonna get married once you're good
full
let's get this in the video drizzy
mary's 23 brides now the pep talk from
tristan comes right before drake makes
his way to the altar well drake isn't
the only one with new music ring the
alarm because beyonce's new single drops
to knight this is not a drill okay queen
b made the subtle announcement in her
instagram bio break my soul is the name
of the song and it's ours at midnight
today's a game with that digital drop
know where you was when that digital pop
i stopped the world
beyonce stopped the world when she
announced last week that her next album
renaissance is coming july 29th it's her
first solo album in six years and
someone who of course has heard the new
music her mama tina we caught up with
her at holly rod foundation's design
care gala i'm a fan too
and i'm very very excited you know i i
just posted recently that i really miss
her singing and i do
so i'm just i'm as excited as everybody
else i can't wait for you guys to hear
it she put two years of love into this
many many nights all night working and
so i can't wait for the for the world to
hear it
can't wait
now from queen b to the rift inside the
royal family so you remember when meghan
markle was accused of bullying
kensington staff well today et has
learned that the palace will not be
releasing the results of their
investigation according to the time the
sunday times they will instead be
improving the policies and procedures in
their hr department citing royal sources
the times says the move is a way to
limit tensions between the sussexes and
the palace and to protect the privacy of
those who took part in the investigation
the queen doesn't want any more drama
she doesn't want to have any more i
think dirty linen aired in public
well according to the times the probe
began in 2018 when megan allegedly drove
two personal assistants from the
household and was undermining the
confidence of a third staff member the
sussex has denied the claims calling it
a calculated smear campaign we don't
know what those allegations were we
don't know how damaging they were
duchess and sussex and
she has very strongly refuted these
bullying allegations what we do know is
that that story came at a pretty
interesting time
yeah they came to light just days before
harry and megan's bombshell interview
with oprah where meg doubled down on the
effects of mudslinging in the media you
say the narrative with kate it didn't
happen
so specifically did you make kate cry no
the reverse happened
and i don't say that
to be disparaging to anyone
meanwhile the future queen consort
camilla parker-bowles is giving a rare
candid glimpse into her marriage with
prince charles in her debut interview
with british vogue out tomorrow she says
balancing their relationship with their
responsibilities isn't easy sometimes
but we do always try to have a point in
the day when we meet she goes on to add
we actually sit and read our books in
different corners of the same room it's
very relaxing because you know you don't
have to make conversations how about
that the duchess also like you and
cassie the dolce practice also reflects
on the scrutiny she's endured
specifically about her affair with
charles while she while he was still
married to princess diana she says
nobody likes to be looked at all the
time and you know criticized but i think
in the end i sort of rise above it and
get on with it you've got to get on with
life
homelessness has always stuck with me as
a topic and as an issue i want to fight
for the future king of england prince
william says he was inspired by his
mother in a new initiative leading up to
his 40th birthday tomorrow the duke of
cambridge hit the streets to sell the
big issue a publication dealt by those
experiencing homelessness to shine a
spotlight on the issue we can fix it i
think that's been a bit of a turning
point in my head where i've seen okay if
we really want to fix services william
also celebrated father's day by sharing
this new pic of the fam that's
eight-year-old prince george
seven-year-old princess charlotte and
four-year-old prince louis right there
at the top
[Music]
this comes just a couple weeks after
prince louis stole the show at the
queen's platinum jubilee
well now on to a soon-to-be father of
nine nick cannon got some love on the
gram from three of his five baby mamas
on father's day abby de la rosa who
already shares twins with nick and is
currently pregnant posted a tribute
video shouting out nick for being a
great dad while playing with their kids
at the park and they spent some time
together over the weekend abby used the
moment to troll him at a nightclub
and the newest baby mama to the bunch
bree tasty also posted a sweet message
for nick calling him the most loving
gentle and present human bree who's due
in a few weeks also showed off her baby
bump no father's day shout out on
instagram from his ex-wife the icon
herself mariah carey instead she posted
a tribute to her late father
nick told us back in november he's not
sure if he's done having kids
i'm not mad at kids this is always a
difficult question because this and this
is probably the issue of like when
you're in an unorthodox situation i
don't know you know what life brings so
to for me to be like no i'm done and
then i you know
i'm walking down the aisle in 2025 you
know you know you never know
jayla's also showing showing some pda on
instagram calling her future husband ben
affleck the most consistent and selfless
daddy ever i love my career but nothing
is more fulfilling to me than being able
to build a family
with someone who i love deeply and who
is just as dedicated to family and and
to each other as we can be and we're
learning a little bit more about what
they were up to over the weekend an
eyewitness tells e.t that they spent
saturday poolside at the beverly hills
hotel they ran into ben's bestie matt
damon there too now jen visited the two
on set of their new nike drama last week
looking bridal and white and while
benefit plan their wedding a source
tells e.t they're so dedicated to each
other and their family
speaking of j-lo performed with her
child emmy on thursday at dodger stadium
for the sixth annual blue diamond gala
[Music]
it's the first time the two have shared
the stage since the super bowl in 2020.
[Applause]
[Music]
she's got her daddy's voice i mean emmy
always could say i remember when she was
in the crib when she was a baby
um she used to
be humming and like really humming to
herself and seeing and and mark would
say
she's singing he's like it feels good to
her it feels good to her soul and to her
like her body
[Music]
i get it i know you got somebody you
want it i get it you needed someone that
could prove you wrong so i reckon
that's another teen with famous parents
the daughter of brad pitt and angelina
jolie shiloh the 16 year old is just one
of several dancers in this video from
millennium dance complex in l.a now the
routine choreographed to vegas by dojika
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's good so good really good wow maybe
we'll see shiloh on tour soon just last
month we saw her at the same place
dancing to lizzo
need a sentimental man a woman to pump
me up feeling fussy walking in my
valencia
let's move on to the sex lives of
college girls executive producer mindy
kaling who's also writing legally blonde
three yeah last night she gave et's
lauren zema an update on the
long-awaited return of l woods which was
originally scheduled for a 2020 release
is obviously so busy with her shows and
it's slow but we are working on it we
have written an amazing part obviously
for reese and elle but for jennifer
coolidge it's really wonderful to be
writing for
two such like relevant and funny
actresses oh love it okay well could we
could we see you in it or on sex lives
of college girls i mean i would die to
be on both shows i don't see a world
where i'm in either of them but listen
yes and i should have some sway
now while mindy hasn't written any
cameos for herself sex lives of college
girls is currently in production for
season two on hbo max and the cast
hasn't stopped dreaming i have pitched
multiple multiple multiple times that
mindy needs to be on the show and also
tina fey needs to be on the show i think
the both of them need to do it and they
both need to do like a comedic duo like
something her is a professor and mindy
is like the dean or like something
incredible we just need to keep
bombarding her with the question and
just being like when are you making your
appearance when when is it what not like
what just or like if it's wet the whole
cast said they want you in the show so
they have to
i'm their boss they're like yeah mindy
would be great
like that would make no sense but yes i
would love it all right more tv news kit
harrington is reportedly reprising his
role as jon snow and another upcoming
game of thrones spin-off what about
everyone else
all the other people who think they know
what's good
[Music]
they don't get to choose
the series is expected to follow snow
after his exile from westeros kit who
won two emmys for the character told e.t
he's embracing the fame that came from
the show
the journey with that is coming to terms
with the fact that i will be and being
proud of that i think that there was a
part of me that fought against it for a
long time in the process since finishing
has been about um being proud of the job
we did being proud of that show being
proud of the character that i created
it's a good thing
moving on to top gun maverick tom and
the cast just wrapped up their world
wide press tour in seoul south korea tom
explained what it took to get this movie
right and it takes
very dedicated unrelenting commitment to
be able to get the highest quality and
that's something that i demand of myself
and i ask of the people that i'm working
with
i mean it's paid off okay the film's box
office is nearing 900 million dollars
worldwide making it tom cruise's most
successful movie yet
kevin hart and woody harrelson on the
other hand are teaming up for a new
buddy comedy it's called the man from
toronto and only e.t can take you to the
set i am the man from toronto objection
no i'm the man from
school i play the man from toronto who
is uh involved in torturing him people
for information
sometimes
killing people so maybe not the best guy
in the world but you know it
judge the deed not the doer woody plays
the world's deadliest assassin kevin is
a screw-up who is mistaken for the man
from toronto after the two somehow end
up in the same airbnb
do this all over your face please please
i knew this wasn't to work does it look
like i'm playing games probably the
hardest part of this role is not
laughing keeping the kids stone-faced
you know
it's like i defy anyone
the movie out june 24th on netflix
co-stars kaylee cuoco and woody develops
a crush on her you're here already
this is kaylee and she's unbelievably
charming but
it doesn't take a great imaginative jump
to see fallen in love with her don't
have to kill me don't never touch me
like that again
[Music]
nailed it
on to even more action do you remember
when george clooney played batman of
course yeah it's been 25 years since he
and robin took on mr freeze but not
before michael keaton made his return as
the dark knight in batman returns
how could you
i'm a woman
i'm sorry i i ugh
it's basically about pure summer
entertainment truthfully you know what
other ruptures a lot of it i just kind
of showed up for work figured i'd pretty
much know what to do when i got
there what would you like to know about
the rib it draws blood
in 1992 michael keaton reprised his role
as the caped crusader facing off against
danny devito as the penguin and joining
forces with catwoman played by michelle
pfeiffer
meow and get this annette benning was
initially cast as selena kyle but after
becoming pregnant with her and warren
beatty's first child she gave up the saw
after role as annette told et at the
time she had no regrets about stepping
down
uh very unconflicted
you know that was
that was it's a great part and i'm very
flattered that michelle pfeiffer is
doing it and i'm sure she'll be terrific
but it was really no contest in terms of
what was more important to me michael
was paid 10 million dollars for the role
and confessed he only took the part
because he needed the cash for a real
estate deal another fun fact michelle
really learned how to use catwoman's
whip just watch this behind the scenes
moment after michelle knocks the heads
off these mannequins in a single take
she gets a round of applause on set
oh and in case you're wondering michelle
revealed decades later not only does she
still have the whip she's still got the
skills
in 1997 the franchise turned to george
clooney to don the bat suit
i freeze i'm batman and enter arnold
schwarzenegger as mr freeze all right
everyone
jill
i thought it was truly like a comic book
coming alive
[Music]
i realized right away from the beginning
that this would entail a lot of makeup
we spend around three and a half hours a
day every morning to put the makeup on
then after that it took an hour to put
the heavy 70 pound armor on
the icemen coming the performances were
great chris o'donnell returned as robin
alicia silverstone joined as batgirl and
uma thurman beat out demi moore and
sharon stone to play poison ivy hell
i am mother nature now that was a
fantastic experience i had to wear lots
of
rubber rubber suits i had some rubber
appliances on my face sometimes that was
about as much rubber as i've ever
worked with personally
as for the sidekick chris later admitted
to e.t it was all about the car up i
grew up as a kid you know i had all the
batman robin toys i watched the tv show
uh it was it was quite a thrill
i got to drive the batmobile for
christ's sakes i mean come on i want a
car
chicks dig the car
this is why superman works alone
i'm not gonna lie chris as robin was my
first cinematic crush i think i think so
uh speaking of crushes now on to little
nasex who's still not over a recent snub
i think we have a long way to go in some
places but i feel like the world is
definitely trying his best to change in
many ways and rupaul's drag race star
trixie mattel is giving her motel a
major makeover we'll take you inside
when et's the download returns
[Music]
lil nazex is still feeling some type of
way about getting snubbed by the bet
awards yet getting zero nominations he
addressed the drama at the songwriters
hall of fame gala where he was being
honored
i think we have a long way to go in some
places but i feel like the world is
definitely trying his best to change in
many ways i'll say that that's a much
different tune than the one he was
literally singing two weeks ago
expressing his frustrations with some
choice words
the network responded to the diss track
saying we are passionate advocates for
the wonderful diversity that exists
within our community and this isn't the
only award show snubbed this year for
him little nazex lost all five
categories he was nominated in at the
grammys now to news that will make fans
of rupaul's drag race happy yeah
breakout star trixie mattel has her own
show et's lauren zema found out the
process has been a little painful
oh my god
i'm
stunned it's like
it feels like i had a baby in me for 18
months wow which means i finally gave
birth to a one-year-old child
so motherhood's been tough
fans first met the amazing trixie mattel
on season seven of rupaul's drag race
and now she's got her own show trixie
motel bringing drag to the renovation
world for people who haven't gotten to
see it yet how would you just describe
the show to them what do they need to
tune in for
well trixie mattel me um i purchased a
motel in the desert with my partner
david and we are renovating it into the
trixie motel which will be a kind of
retro pink 60s desert paradise
but we're on a limited budget and it all
had to happen in four months give me
some more of the numbers so four months
four months budget of the property was
1.9 million dollars and the budget was
half a million dollars that comes out
about 2.4 seven rooms with custom
wallpapers custom linens
you know i hope no one breaks anything
because everything in these rooms is one
of a kind
during the one-of-a-kind series
streaming now on discovery plus stars
like zoe deschanel leslie jordan and
lisa vanderpump lend a helping hand
let's give it a try i've got to do a lot
of cool things as trixie but something
like owning a motel i mean
and then being able to document this as
a series it's like having the scrapbook
of the most stressful thing you've ever
done renovating is a lot harder than
comedy performing tap dancing i mean
anything else i've done pales in
comparison to the financial stress and
the the stakes we're only on you know a
few episodes in but spoiler alert i mean
this this motel is the most beautiful
place in the world we kept it simple and
spent money on the things that you
notice
trixie and her partner in love and
business david flipped this palm springs
motel with
lgbtqia plus visitors in mind and also
give fans a rare peek into their
relationship when you introduce this new
stress and this new dream together
now you're trying to like it's like our
baby really
so it really puts your relationship to
the test but i mean i came out of it
being
more in love with him than ever what was
it like for you guys to be on camera
together that much well anybody who's
followed me knows that we've been
together almost six years and i never
tag him i never post pictures of him i
keep my relationship very private i'm
like obnoxious look at me look at me and
he just has a very calm
normal human being energy it's a good
balance as a drag queen i don't always
feel safe at hotels and what about for
you to be brian on camera so much how
did that feel
i'm always embarrassed to be on camera
out of drag it makes me uncomfortable
but in the ball springs heat six hours
into the day i was like get the makeup
wipe you have to admit i'm you know a
caucasian bald and sweating i look like
i belong in palm springs if you drink
enough alcohol you can fly anywhere how
would you compare the nerves of doing
this show for the first time to when you
were first on drag race
drag race is worse is it yes it's much
worse at least with renovation you can
make mistakes as you go in a competition
environment there are no mistakes there
are there's doing well and there's
packing your bags
trixie of course is living out loud and
proud and so is a female baseball legend
maybelle blair she is coming out as gay
at 95 years old maybelle is one of the
women who inspired the 90s film a league
of their own and she revealed she's a
lesbian at a screening for the new
amazon series of the same name now e.t
was with madonna who played all the way
may at the movie premiere 30 years ago
it was hard work hard work it was 106
degrees 120 on the field a lot of people
passed out yeah a lot of puking what are
your strong points in the basement about
strengths in every area
hello
maybe i'll pitch for the peoria red
wings in 1948 then played sports for six
more years before becoming a student at
compton college near l.a that's
incredible look at her 95 years young
huh i know we love to see it well that
does it for us today join us right here
tomorrow for a new episode of et's the
download bye everyone
[Music]